over here i've drawn part of the graph
of y is equal to x squared and what
we're going to do is use our powers of
definite integrals to find volumes
instead of just areas so let's review
what we're doing when we take just a
regular definite integral so if we take
the definite integral between say 0 and
2 of x squared
dx what does that represent let's look
at our endpoints so this is x is equal
to 0. let's say that this right over
here is x is equal to 2.
what we're doing is at e for each x
we're finding a little dx around it so
this right over here is a little dx and
we're multiplying that dx times our
function times x squared so what we're
doing is we're multiplying this with
times this height
times this height right over here the
height right over here is x squared and
we're getting the area of this little
rectangle and the integral sign is
literally the sum of all of these
rectangles all of these rectangles for
all of the x's between x is equal to 0
and x is equal to 2 but the limit of
that as these dx's get smaller and
smaller and smaller get infinitely small
with not being equal to zero and we have
an infinite number of them that's the
whole power of the definite integral and
so you can imagine as these dx's get
smaller and smaller and smaller these
rectangles get narrower and narrower
narrower and we have more of them we are
getting a better and better
approximation of the area under the
curve until at the limit we are getting
the area under the curve now we're going
to play apply that same idea not to find
the area under this curve but to find
the volume if we were to rotate this
curve around the x-axis so this is going
to stretch our powers of visualization
here so let's think about what happens
when we rotate this thing around the
x-axis so let me so let's here to rotate
it and i'll look at say we're looking a
little bit from the right so we get kind
of a base that looks something like this
so this is my best attempt to draw it
so you have a base
that looks something like that and then
the rest of the function it looks kind
of like
if we just think about it between zero
and two it looks like one of those
pieces from i don't know if you ever
played the game sorry
or it looks like a little bit of a kind
of a weird hat
so it looks like this and let me shade
it in a little bit
shade it in
a little bit so it looks something like
that and just so that we're making sure
we can visualize this thing that's being
rotated we care about the entire volume
of the thing let me draw it from a few
different angles so if i drew it from
the top if i do it from the top it would
look something like this
become a little more obvious it looks
something like a hat
point up like this and
it goes down
like that it would look something like
that so we're not seeing in this angle
we're not seeing the we're not seeing
the bottom of it
and if you were to just to orient
yourself if you were to orient yourself
the axes in this case look like this so
this is the y-axis
that is the y-axis and then the x-axis
goes right inside of this thing and then
pops out
pops out the other side and if this
thing was transparent
then you could see
you could see the back side it would
look something like that the x-axis the
x-axis if you could see through it would
pop the base right over there
would go right through the base right
over there and then come out on the
other side so this is one orientation
for the same thing you could visualize
it from different angles
so let's think about how we can take the
volume of it
well instead of thinking about the area
of each of these rectangles what happens
if we rotate each of these rectangles
around the x-axis
so let's do it
so let's take each of these
let's say you have this dx right over
here and you rotate it around the x-axis
so if you were to rotate this thing
around the x-axis so i'm trying my best
to
around the x-axis you rotate it what do
you end up with
what do you end up with well you get
something that looks kind of like a coin
like a like a disc like a like a quarter
of some kind let me draw it out here so
if you were that same disc out here
would look something like this
it would look something
it would look something like this and it
has
it has a depth of
of
dx
so how can we find the volume of that
disk let me redraw it out here too
it's really important to visualize this
stuff properly so this is
my x-axis
my disk looks something like my disk
looks something like this my best
attempt
the x-axis hits it right over there
comes out of the center and then this is
the surface
of
of my disk and then this right over here
is my depth dx
so
that looks pretty good and then let me
just shade it in a little bit to give
you a little bit of the depth so how can
we find the volume of this
well like any disc or cylinder you just
have to think about what the area of
this face is and then multiply it times
the depth so what's the area of this
face
well we know that the area of a circle
is equal to pi
r squared so if we know the radius of
this face
if we know the radius of this face we
can figure out the area of the face
well what's the radius well the radius
is just the height of that original
rectangle and for any x the height over
here is going to be equal to f of x and
in this case f of x is x squared
so over here our radius is equal to x
squared radius is equal to x squared so
the area of the face for a particular x
is going to be equal to
area is going to be equal to pi
times
f of x squared in this case f of x is x
squared
f of x is x squared now what's our
volume going to be well our volume is
going to be our area times the depth
here
it's going to be that times the depth
times dx
times dx so the volume of this thing
right over here
so my
the volume just of my of this this this
coin i guess you could call it is going
to be equal to so my volume is going to
be equal to my area
times dx
which is equal to pi times x squared
squared so it's equal to pi
x squared squared is x to the fourth pi
x to the fourth dx
x to the fourth
d
x now this expression right over here
this gave us the volume just of one of
those discs but what we want is the
volume of this entire hat or this entire
kind of bugle or co or cone looking
organized together the front of a
trumpet looking thing so how could we do
that well the exact same technique what
happens if we were to take
the sum
of all of these things so let's do that
take the sum of all of these things and
i'll switch to one color pi times x to
the fourth dx we're gonna take the sum
of all of these things from x is equal
to zero to two those are the boundaries
that we started off with i just defined
them arbitrarily we could do this really
for any two x values between x is equal
to zero and x equals two and we're gonna
take the sum of all of these all the
volumes of all of these coins but the
limit as these as the depths get smaller
and smaller and smaller and we have more
and more and more coins at the limit
we're actually going to get the volume
of our cone or our bugle or whatever we
want to call it so if we just evaluate
this definite integral we have our
volume so let's see if we can do that so
this is and now this is just taking a
standard definite integral so this is
going to be equal to and i encourage you
to try it out before i do it so we could
take the pi out so it's going to be
equal to pi
times the integral from 0 to 2
of x to the fourth dx i don't like that
color
now the anti-derivative of x to the
fourth is x to the fifth over five so
this is going to be equal to pi
times
x to the fifth
over five and we're gonna go from zero
to two so it's going to be equal to pi
times this thing evaluated at two let's
see two to the third is eight two to the
fourth is sixteen two to the fifth is
let me actually just write it down two
to the fifth
over five
minus zero to the fifth
over five and this is going to be equal
to 2 to the fifth is 32 so it's going to
be equal to pi
times 32
over 5 minus well this is just 0 minus 0
which is equal to 32
pi
over 5. and we're done we were able to
figure out this the volume of this kind
of wacky shape